what do you think about having kids I
think about that it's you'll be a great
dad
I don't think we need to go there right
this is the first date
hi everyone my name is Freddie and I
just saw crazy rich Asians and it was
amazing my friend Mai reminds me so much
of Rachel she's strong she's determined
she's funny and I want her to meet that
perfect guy to the film definitely
highlights the importance of getting
along with your boyfriend's family
especially an overbearing mother so I've
come up with a plan to help Maya with
that too I'm gonna set her up on three
blind dates but what she doesn't know is
that the moms are gonna be on the dates
with her so I got a few submissions from
some potential suitors for Maya and I'm
really excited to see who would be a
good fit hey my name is Bryan Choi but
Bruce my friends call me Panda I as well
have a group of hobbies but I think
maybe the strangest one I can point out
is being able to play Scottish Highland
Bagpipe so these are my black McCallum's
from high school okay so Maya's very
musical she's seeing she plays guitar
she plays piano they could have some
stuff in common Here I am very into
comedy love going to comedy shows and
laughing meditation yoga more spiritual
stuff I am I dating apps I don't do well
on dating apps I understand it's hard
out here in these streets that's why I'm
putting them together
IRL next is Shawn hey Shawn I'm a bit of
a hobbyist actually I enjoy cycling
playing the guitar I like to do arts and
crafts okay so he enjoys cycling and he
said he's very musical he plays the
guitar the piano perfect for Maya okay
so I think I've chosen the guys they all
seem to have a pretty good head on their
shoulders so hopefully the dates go well
my parents met on a blind date Wow same
with Prince Harry and Megan Marco I know
right and now look at them did you get
me a Prince Harry did you get our Prince
Harry
ish
hello how's it going hi nice to meet you
a shot you pleasure
are you Maya hi Bryan can I be with you
guys of course
okay we should get some drinks yeah sure
hi this is my mother terrible first
impression I guess oh it's fine I just
talk a lot different good listener oh
good
oh my god Thank You Shawn my baby can I
join you
sure mom thank you
oh my gosh his mama's so cute you guys
travel a lot I do I tried to make him
cry but more often I didn't do improv
then I got to stand up and now I do
something called clown talk all right I
could be into cloud very good boy I'm a
little bit protective but it's it's I
guess a novel right yeah it's your mold
I mean I'm a crossing history one do you
remember what Judy told you about when
you have a girlfriend
his sister commented him okay Bryan when
you tape it the girl first thing you
have to respect her okay so you have to
respect her it's a deal-breaker you
can't compromise on having kids so I
never even said I wanted kids you mean
you're not gonna break it
he's been in love a couple of times
deeply in love it's all I was like
really quickly yes I feel like
butterflies and the emotional rush of it
and it'll be like my logical brain
that's like though yeah and your mom
telling you stop it oh yeah she's very
quick to yes that's all my Abuelita what
type of man you if I may go for I think
someone who can handle their own and I
don't feel like I'd have to be a certain
way in order for his masculine need to
be okay
just like someone who wouldn't bring him
I'm on a date what no I'm confident to
have the mother on a date yeah that is a
lot of confidence I like her so what do
you think about my son didn't like to go
in a baby
well you know it's a great son and he's
handsome and very passionate I bet it
without a lot on at all
I can tell yes yes what a doozy today
was I feel exhausted I feel exhausted
motional exhausted so how did you feel
about getting back into the dating game
I know it's been a little bit do you
think the mom's helped I maybe a little
bit I think it definitely made me more
confident which is kind of weird I don't
know why I had such a weird perception
about dating I felt comfortable I was
fine and like if I could do it in front
of the mom
then it's fine everywhere else who do
you think you'd go on a second date with
I felt a connection with Shawn and his
mom just because and I just love the
kind of energy in the vibe that they
came off it was like a magnet like I
feel like we attracted each other a
little bit
yes I that I got that vibe yeah I felt
the connection between the two of you
the surprise is that you will be going
on a second date it'll be a VIP
screening to the new movie crazy rich
Asians oh well you know I think so
highly of you I think that you deserve
your own love story and I think that
this was a great start
I don't know I first so long I just
thought that I kind of wasn't worthy of
it or like it wasn't for me I was so
focused on my work and now this is just
honestly like opened me up so much to
new experiences being okay to like fail
or be embarrassed I think that's a big
thing with love is like you just you
just have to fall in it you know and who
knows what could happen
all right everyone the movie's supposed
to start I gotta put my phone away okay
[Music]